ve
aleyna
Burada olmaktan dolayı çok kötü onu
duyuyorum yeni anaokulları ve ailesine
Çok teşekkür ederim
bu vallahi dedi bulunduğumuz yerden alır
ve başka bir yere koyar bedava değil
buradan devam yalnız
16'da
olacaktım Annem değeriyle
pazarcı oldu ama
[Müzik]
yeni başlamayı çok seviyorum başarmak mı
daha çok para kazanmak mı dediniz her
zaman başarılı seçelim
var ya sanırım o bileceğim
Okulu bırakmak zorunda kalmış aynı
nedenlerden dolayı mağazasında en büyük
hayali okumamış oğlum
kendine
Türkiye'de üretim yapan da
[Müzik]
o
dedi ki babası Türkiye'de meyve sebze
üretiminde
Ondan sonra hayatımı bana sadece olacak
çıktıktan sonra şimdi dedim kendime ben
onu neden düşünmedim bugüne kadar birçok
Ticaret yapmanın finansmanını yönetirken
neden kendi aynı şirketimizi göremedim
o gün kurumsal aya beğenir çeşit çok
olmadığı önce etmedim bırakacağım sonra
çevreme gelen giden emanet de çok
başarısının çok çalıştım müdür olacaksın
bırakamaz
ama bıraktım
Oh
be önce Durmaz sararmış olacaktım
bıraktıktan sonra nasıl başlayacağız
Ayrıca fikrim yoktu Sadece bir yakadan
başlamalı gerektiğini biliyorum
bu tığla ipi şirketlerle şirketimiz
babam Veysel paylaşmayacağım oldu
üretmeye üretim yapıyor ve toptan satış
yapıyorduk ama sonucu geçici yani
evlerdeki mutfak bizi tanımıyordu bir
ürettiğimiz ürünleri aracı olan
kanalında tüketicilere gönderiyoruz
tüketiciler çek at
[Müzik]
Bu ikinci bir nerede burcudur bakmasın
kabında da kardeşlerim böyle
geldiğimizde en uygun konuşuyor ve
değişen tüketici ihtiyaçlarını birlikte
onların Ulaşırız ı sorgulamadım
taşıyorum dalından sofraları
bu
şuydu bugün dalında Yarın tezgahta
gün bugün dalında ya da
olsa da
[Müzik]
bu
ne kadar uzun çok kısa zamanda batarsın
dedim de onun için sordum internet
alabilirsiniz
internetten mısınız diye
işte o
[Müzik]
abone ol
Ben
40 yıllık Hey bundan sonra taşıma
Aslında birincil ikinizin birbirinize
burcuydu Bundan dolayı u yola çıkmaya
karar verdim çok için hoşuna ülkeleri
çok çalışmaya başlar ya işte ben de
sadece 2'de yatıyor sabah 5'te
kalkıyorum Burası yapamaz vazgeçecek ve
namazları vardı ama ben vazgeçmiyorum
Çünkü aile ve
açtıktan sonra ilk kez
[Müzik]
bir su bardağı döndükten sonra yapabilir
modelin Orada fark ettim aracı araştıran
11 kalabilirim
O kırmızı o kadar yürüyecek yapan Ben
şimdi elimde meyve saldırıyla
belli teslimat yapacaktım geliyorsun
ederim için nasıl anlatırım bir insanım
var beni ekinin vardı kafamda deli
sorular
bu sonra 10 dakika sonra dedim ki Ayşe
eğer tam bir şeyin anladıysan göreviniz
Uysal şimdi çift bu arabada önce satış
önce kendimi taşıdım Evet ederim İyi ki
çıkmış Bu arada
hayatımın en büyük mottosu ne yaparsan
yap farklı O yüzden farklı yapayım Evet
mesaj atacaktım ama
insanlar sadece Taze değil
O yüzden
diyorum ya
şu anda var onları çok sorulan
sorulardan bir tanesi iş vazgeçme
düşündünüz mü istersen da çok düşündüm
bildiğiniz varsa atıyorum seni çalışan
benim
Aracımın ya koltuğu tavana kadar dolu
arkada oldu tavana kadar dolup bagaj zor
kullanıyorum akşam 5.00 15 kişiye 15
fazla acısı sipariş etmekten gerekiyor
Saat siparişleri 6'da bitmesi gerekiyor
Yani bir saat var su içmemişim kırmızı
çıkar da paylaşıyorum inanılmaz yoğun
durdum
yapamayacağım arkadaşım
[Müzik]
eve gidiyorum eve
bu
ama yazmış Mazda neler olacağını
bilmiyoruz Ben de bugün o gün belki de
bugün kaderinin değiştiği
O da orada elini saat sonra geldi
itfaiye bir çevrede dağıttık e sipariş
teslim edildi
değişti günlük
ettiğimizi düşündüğümüz anlar oluyor
bazen geleceğimiz düşündüğümüz
yapamadığımızı başladığımız düşündüğümüz
Anladım insan suçu Ayrılamam Evet babası
yaşamıyoruz hatalar yapıyoruz duygusal
davranıyoruz insanların içinde kalıyoruz
düşünüyoruz
bu durumlarda bir şey var
Yapabileceğimiz varsa eğer
hiçbir zaman vazgeçmeniz gerekiyor zor
biliyorum Ama
başarılı güç para kimse Xavi ile tavadan
iyiyim bunun böyle var mı var Ben her
sabah 5'te işe gidiyorum şirketi kurduk
Üç yıl oldu bu ara mesajı gidiyoruz iş
uzun bir gün gün kalktım ve iyi parça
oturdu Tamam o yüzden şey de o zaman mm
var bir takipçi akşam diye geldiniz
dedim ki Niye Yani ilk para şu benim
işte Asıl bu dünyadan gerekiyor demek ki
bir sorun var mı sipariş Oku Bugün
bulmamız gerekiyor
bitirdim dediğimiz
çalışmakla beraber zeka ile beraber
atıyla beraber sizi başarıya götürecek
en büyük unutmayınız Eğer gittiğimiz
yoksa başarılı olur olmazsa olmaz
sıfırdan başladım hiçbir şey yapmamışım
O yüzden şimdi var olduklarımın suyla
havasıyla gururuyla durursa mi Ne oldu
ki
[Müzik]
Ben hiçbir şey yapmama gerek yok dediniz
Evet varsa aslında kaybetmeye oradan
başlayacaksınız çünkü Özgüven şeyin
fazlası Haydi bazzart Bugün buradayım
Selam bugün de razıyım çünkü olmaz
denilenleri
aldırmadım yapamazsın diyenlere duymadım
doğrudan buradan hiç açmadım sadece bir
de farklı
bugün
[Müzik]
Hikaye Eski
Hikaye şu anda
[Müzik]
sadece inanmalı çalışmalı ve her zaman
şu an başlamamız Bazen hayat bilgisi
sağır ve başka bir yeter ve derki
buradan devam et o
[Alkış]